Blue Rock Project to create the world's best egoist striker from 300 high school students
Those who drop out lose the right to represent Japan for the rest of their lives
Extreme survival
An unknown high school forward
Yoichi Isaki
fights against many rivals and
knocks them out
himself  Awakening my ego
I'll become stronger with Blue Rock
Team X,
remember, you bastards
Peach's Major I'm the
king You know, a
guy who freaks out until the goal does
n't qualify as a striker
You're talented, you
're
disqualified as a striker
[MUSIC]
You have the same eyes as me, but I
can't win
I'm the one who's in control of the game.
I
'm a striker It
feels good
[music]
Let's go
I want to play soccer again This is a torn
ice horse
My life was full of boredom
Until I met soccer and Kiyoshiro Nagi
It's
annoying to be a weak guy, don't worry about it,
you're a genius.
My ego says I want to fight this guy
[music]
I want to play soccer with
this guy I'm sure I'll win It's a stepping stone for me
The next selection will start broadcasting on Saturday, January 7, in the TV Asahi
Nikkei National Network
Numa animation frame.